lui c'est lui c'est le cinéma pourquoi
pas je me rappelle moi même justement un
jour avoir parti pis et à une avoir
participé à une superproduction
reggaemen une production mais qui
réparait qui mène aux usa et éducatives
en même temps mais sur les classiques
français justement
et là c'était une scène non on ne badine
pas avec ma le savez une page fan de ski
ne badine pas avec l'amour la faute
d'avoir un papa avec la fausse staff ait
de suites daf de la misère de sang bref
la scène deux séduit 2 avec père dit que
verdict 1 mg accueilli à leurs matinées
d'éveil mois camille camille et brainois
à vous l'auriez vu et moi même je la
voyais pour la première fois aussi folie
dans sa petite robe avec son dock
taubaté qu'évident et son décolleté son
décolleté très bas d'ailleurs toute
fraîche que c'est s'attirer tout seul
c'est à dire ça a ses rites et
vraiment vraiment vraiment innocente
reprenant le personnage et moi j'ai faim
tout immédiatement je sentirai trac fou
enfin vous pouvez plus ces nations voilà
que j'entends un cri moteur gris le
moteur enseigne le message mais seul le
réalisateur et le machiniste claque ça
tapait tu tapes sa claquette face à
pareil on ne badine pas si 112e bref un
silence mais un silence nar entendîmes
violé une bouche on a entendu voler une
mouche viol est un viol
tellement c'était là moi je suis pris
par l'émotion
comme je commence à dés les premiers
pots vous pouvez me croire
baylet prg au niveau des machines were
sortie d'un chimiste
il s'appelait machinistes sortez les
mouchoirs si ils y voyaient même aux
endroits où on ne rit pas d'habitude
mais ça il était restée miville
franchement ça fait partie du maquis et
camille qui me répond au souhait de
faire vous me vous me faites peur mais
c'est à ce moment là qu est l
elle bafouille est la malheureuse il ya
d'impasse mona moi je ne perds pas mon
françois au contraire bon sang froid je
lui dis va te maquilles battant
d'ailleurs ce texte retourne à ton
moulin etc
vous savez vous connaissez tous les
hommes sont menteurs inconstant vos faux
bavard hippocrate il corpo creux y croit
peu orgueilleux il
ils sont tous comme ça et toutes les
femmes sont son père fille artificieuse
archi vicieuse vaniteuse mais on aime et
on peut se dire c'est moi qui ai vécu et
non un être factrice créée par mon
orgueil et mon envie c'est à ce moment à
part mon envie par mon compte ailleurs à
ce moment-là frôlant la couper et il
faut vous dire elle devait me casser
pourquoi une fausse peau tête sur la
tige une
protège sur la structure de sur le crâne
elle se trompe en salle d'à côté qui
était en marche
tu vois je tombe en syncope au moins et
que le marché de la gestion qui est
arrivé et qui m'a dit bravo
bon pour le son tout ce que j'entends et
puis fait leçon c'était moi et quand
même musée
[Musique]